so some school districts choosing to
close down as cova cases go up my next
guest is pushing for federal funding to
help kids switch from virtual schools to
allow in-person learning illinois
republican congressman rodney davis
joins me now congressman tell me your
plan first of all well first off ed
thanks for having me on and it's great
to follow a report on on governor elect
yunkan who will be sworn in today
because the epicenter of the frustration
with our schools was right there during
the virginia election and what this bill
does it simply allows money that's
already been appropriated in the
american rescue plan to allow students
and parents if your school district is
shut down you can take up to ten
thousand dollars and move your move your
child to a neighboring school district
another public school district that
remains open because we know schools
being open
make sure our kids learn better right so
you introduced the open schools act how
much would that plan cost you're talking
about ten thousand dollars per student
it would follow the student not the
school
it would follow the student it allows
parents to be back in charge which were
you know which was the epicenter in
loudoun county virginia that helped
glenn younkin and historic republican
victories there
but our bill would take money that's
already been appropriated it's already
been
it's already been voted on it's in the
american rescue plan
without any obligation so let's give
parents a chance to get their kids back
in school you know
these shutdowns of our schools they hurt
those who have worked the pandemic the
entire time those who are in the
services right no i wanna and i'm
running out of time here unfortunately
we're up against a heartbreak i wanted
to ask you about this unraveling story
the secretary of education actually
asking the national school board
association for the letter comparing
parents to domestic terrorists i'm going
to get your thoughts on that
in the last 15 seconds you know we need
to we need to make sure we investigate
whether or not the biden administration
through the secretary of education
asked the national school board
association to determine whether or not
parents parents who care about their
kids who are going to use their first
amendment right to protest at a school
board meeting to be labeled domestic
terrorists what kind of administration
would propose any association or any
organization to do that it's very
disappointing and we need to get to the
bottom of it because
we do administrations in education
matter yeah congressman i appreciate the
breaks coming whether i like it or not i
appreciate your time congressman rodney
davis from illinois